le lendemain de l'élection fédérale
les révélations profondément troublant
de nos collègues enquêtes ont
inévitablement
éclipser d'autres enjeux cette semaine
fait que certains sujets sont passés
sous le radar pour en discuter je jouais
marie-hélène tremblay à québec
et cette semaine c'est mon collègue
danielle thibeault à ottawa qui va
prendre la relève de yves malo daniel on
a beaucoup parlé des primes de départ
des députés à québec mais on apprend
qu'il soucis à tahoua la question se
pose où il y en a aussi des primes à
tahoua et je vous dirais qu'après les
résultats de lundi il y en a
probablement quelques vins qui vont
réviser le chapitre ce chapitre là du
guide dit à des parlementaires autres
cieux à part ceux qui sont présentés là
aux élections il ya 123 députés qui
n'ont pas été réélus au lundi aux
élections 53 de ceux là sont au québec
là il ya deux catégories pour ces
députés là il y en a qui ont plus de six
ans de service ont droit à une
allocation de retraite et un paquet
quelques les critères j'ai pas mes
calculs là dessus d'eux c'est un peu
complexe mais bon et puis il ya l'autre
catégorie qui eux reçoivent une
allocation de départ
combiné avec le retrait de ce qu'ils ont
versé au régime des rentes de retraite
bon donc ça c'est les députés de la
gauche par exemple par exemple à 20,3 au
québec là dessus je les ai comptés ce
matin cela va recevoir donc ce qu'ils
ont versé comme cotisations au régime de
retraite et ils vont aussi recevoir la
moitié d'un an de salaire
ça équivaut à 83 1700 dollars c'est
quand même pas mal ça va leur permettre
probablement d'éponger un peu la
tristesse du résultat de lundi est de
faciliter la transition entre koch
j'espère c'est le but de ces locations
là et à linverse marie-hélène c'est les
élections fédérales sont dernière nous
ça recommence du côté de certaines
circonscriptions québécoises pour le 9
novembre exactement en fait ces
élections partielles ont été déclenchées
par philippe couillard début octobre en
pleine campagne électorale fédérale
et il va sans dire que les partis
d'opposition ont adressé des reproches
là dessus au premier ministre philippe
couillard parce qu'il bénéficiait quand
même d'un délai de six mois pour tenir
ces élections partielles
alors non patchées encore des affiches
électorales bien
vu dans quatre circonscriptions au
québec c'est henri sainte anne et fabre
dans la région de montréal rené lévesque
sur la côte nord est beau sud dans la
région de québec alors les chiffres ont
été assez discret je vous dirais
emmanuel depuis le lancement de ces
élections partielles mais ont évidemment
on pense que ça va commencer à s'activer
parce qu'on est à deux semaines
maintenant de 9 novembre donc et de
cette date d'élection ce qu'ils font
c'est bien sûr se rappeler c'est que
quand même eu en dix huit mois parce que
le gouvernement couillard c'est a été
élu en avril 2014
il ya quand même eu neuf démission de
parlementaires ce qui est quand même
beaucoup
le dernier en lice si stéphane bédard
c'est survenu il ya à peine quelques
jours et ce sera intéressant de voir si
philippe couillard sera intéressé de
déclencher cette élection partielle
rapidement parce que le comté de
chicoutimi c'est une circonscription
péquiste depuis une quarantaine d'années
et ça coûte de l'argent aux
contribuables des élections partielles
plus d'un demi million de dollars à
chaque fois et à chaque fois qu'il y ait
un départ d'un parlementaire à québec
le feeling le sempiternel débat
justement qui refait surface ces sept
justement cette question de prime de
départ que les députés touchent a chaque
fois et bien sûr à chaque fois il ya des
questionnements là dessus le débat va se
poursuivre jusqu'à ce que le
gouvernement légifère finalement 1 comme
une audi voudrais le remercier d'avoir
été avec nous aujourd'hui
au revoir au revoir et voilà c'est ce
qui conclut cette édition des coulisses
du pouvoir au nom de toute l'équipe vous
remercie d'avoir été des nôtres et
daniel thibault sera à la barre de
l'émission la semaine prochaine